foreign
hey everybody yeah it's Sunday and here
we are talking about a goddamn movie and
guess what we went to the [__]
theater and saw this yeah when was the
last time we went to the theater to see
probably Crimes of the future we went to
the closer AMC over here yeah we hadn't
been to this one before it's by the
Ichiban Buffet yeah and it's in a [__]
up Mall
yeah Lake Square Mall yeah it's fine
look it up in Eustis or Mount door I
don't know I don't know where it's at
that [__] was redneck as [__] it was
yeah yeah
um [__] well this whole area is super
redneck it's very rural and uh you go
there and me and Jenny realize how
good-looking we are we're like man we're
the hottest people yeah we're the
hottest people buy a substantial March
only people that were hotter than us
were under 20. everybody over 20 was
missing teeth no just they were dead
they just a lot of a lot of uh obesity
going on over there so uh
we go to go see uh they don't have Dolby
Theater no IMAX no IMAX none of that
[__] it's just basic it's a 12 theater
AMC yeah 12 and it's in two sections
yeah which is weird it's like one's on
one side one's on the other side of the
mall right it's weird
um
so he went in there just bought basic
tickets it was like six bucks a person
seven something seven seven dollars and
sixty nine cents well because we went in
the afternoon and like it's 30 off if
you go in the afternoon and actually the
uh the seats were pretty nice they were
kind of like the Dolby seats where you
could recline back they were pretty
pretty wide because all the fat people
I was glad because when I was sitting
there thinking look they don't even they
didn't have Dolby or IMAX or nothing
yeah and I'm sitting there going oh man
are we gonna have to send those like
uncut I'm so spoiled we have those
[__] uncomfortable like theater seats
but I guess all of the theaters have
like the nice recliner like a big poofy
like scents now that I can actually kind
of sit cross-legged in because they're
so big and um
we're going in there and the [__]
theater was packed
yeah it was almost full and we went at
the and it was in two different theaters
like at because there was one there was
a showing at noon we couldn't make that
one because we were running late but we
went to the 145 one and it was like and
it was packed it was a Saturday so we're
running two two theaters in their pack
and it was packed at the early shows
um
packed and it was [__] nice man tell
you one thing about [__] uh uh
rednecks there [__] quiet in the
movie They just they listened that whole
[__] movie it really did it's like
you know they laughed and stuff like
that like at appropriate times when the
movie was over they gave it they gave it
Applause yeah
all right this movie here I've seen all
the other uh Mission Impossibles I like
Mission Impossible I have it up there
with Daniel Craig
uh Janice Bond the later ones like the
last three or four
um I guess the last three of them some
of the early ones you know the John Wu
one uh was was good but it was just kind
of dated everybody kind of hates that
one I mean that hates it but that's
usually people's least favorite it is
yeah I don't I didn't like it either it
didn't it didn't age well it's like a
karate flip yeah or it was shot like a
karate flick but um this movie here
okay you don't have to see the other
Mission Impossible movies too I mean it
helps but you don't have to I've seen it
Standalone I can't remember them
I had to go back and look at it again
because there's some of the characters
reappear yeah the White Widow comes back
I remembered her like as soon as because
we saw Fallout in the theater but I
don't think we've seen it yet since then
this one here is the [__] best one
this movie's [__] awesome I think I
like Fallout slightly more still but
this one was pretty Kick-Ass I like this
one man I Gotta See Fallout again I
don't have that one on Blu-ray I gotta
go back through my mission impossible
inventory and see which ones I'm missing
and I'll buy them but uh this movie is
badass and uh man
we're not going to do spoilers per se
but because I mean this just came out it
just came out
oh what makes this one different is that
um
the enemy that they're fighting
is AI
yeah like an AI like a self-aware AI
entity it was a like an Espionage type
program that was made by I think I think
it was the US it was the US government
wasn't it didn't they originally make it
and it got out yeah and it became
started eating up all the damn
information in the internet and became
self-aware and then
tooks took means to protect itself and
to try to take over the world it's
higher in agents it's [__] sending
people at you it's not just in
cyberspace it's doing [__] on its own
yeah it's doing [__] on its own it's
causing accidents to happen of different
kinds
uh it's agents it can Shield them
like they don't show up on any of the
security cameras yeah because they
because the AI yeah that was pretty cool
you can go in there and blot out their
images and you'll never see them like
they're cloaked you can see them face to
face but you can't see them in any
security
array security cameras it's just and a
bunch of weird [__] happens and it's
trying to uh
it knows it it pretty much knows the
possible futures of anything that it
does
so it can predict who will do what based
on your [__] all your metadata
and um
there's a bunch of spies trying to get
it
good yeah because everybody wants this
[__] well the McGuffin at the heart of
it is this key it's like a two-part
two-part key it looks like a cross kind
of like a 3D sort of cross and they're
not really sure they know that this has
something to do with the AI and
something to do with um how they can
destroy it or use it or whatever so it's
like everybody is trying to get the two
halves of this key and like rip them
together it's it's bad guy spies they're
working for governments
um except one of them one of them is
basically this thing's Messiah
yeah it believe this guy believes he's
kind of like a spot
he believes that this thing is God it's
his God
you know he's and he's [__] weird
he's good he's like it's Emissary he's
like his Emissary that's the acai
Morales is um yeah I haven't seen him in
a movie in a while but um yeah I always
really liked him he sees it as a
superior being and he's he he's
hell-bent to serve it and to basically
make it make its [__] well fulfilled
and it's not really they never really
didn't say what it's trying to do you're
not supposed to know because this is
this is only part one
yeah it's a three-hour movie it's part
one yeah it's like two hours and 45
minutes it didn't feel like it though no
it went fast
man I was lucky I only had to piss once
but the seconds I know I was I was
thinking that he was gonna have to like
hold on and the thing about it is leave
the theater man because everything is
important see that's what I'm saying
there's really no there's no slow part
so it's not like you can like luckily
for me even though I had chugged like a
huge [__] coffee like before the
movie which was probably unwise but um I
was actually able to sit through the
whole movie without having to get up to
pee I kind of thought about I was like
maybe I should get it but I was like nah
nah I can hold it it's all right
um but yeah I was surprised that you
only got up one time actually but I
don't think hardly anybody got up I
didn't see him nobody I didn't really
see anybody get up to go to the bathroom
because like I said it's not like
because you know how in some movies
they're like ah it doesn't look like
anything exciting's gonna happen for a
little while I can like duck out to the
to the can but it's like you really
didn't want to no leave like at any
point it starts off with a bag so it
starts off with it with a submarine
Mission some Russian Subs and submarine
warfare and that goes on
for a good 20 minutes and then the CR in
the beginning yeah that's like the
prequel like a prequel yeah and it's
good and you don't really find out what
the significance of that is until like
kind of later until later yeah and
there's a reason why all this happens
um
but yeah I can't wait to see part two
and Tom Cruise knocks it out of the park
he's great the whole thing every the
whole cast Vin rangs Ving Rhames he's
[__] fantastic in it I love him
anyway I love him and everything yeah
he's got some really good scenes uh the
Scottish guy is [__] really good
seven Peg yeah he's really good in it he
was in Shawn of the Dead you remember
that one yeah that's kind of weird
yeah that was his big breakout role was
shot of the Dead um
there's uh two female characters in
there one from one of the prior movies
uh who's like uh she she works uh on in
the IMF and then there's a
kind of a new recruit that they pick up
she's uh she's a thief she's a super
Thief she's like a pickpocket yeah and
she can do rules and she was working for
the AI but it wasn't it no no she was
hired she was hired by that by somebody
wow she didn't know who it was though
she was hired by somebody to find the
key to find the half of the key yeah and
uh and you know pick it up yeah and she
turns she she is a cool character
um it's just I can't
the [__] stunts are good Tom Cruise
[__] delivers he does some cool
motorcycle [__]
all the stunts in there you know and I'm
not I don't impress easily okay but it's
just like you know they used a little
bit of CGI in this like to clean up some
[__] but you know like remove wires and
stuff but um yeah as far as I know this
was you know like 95 practical effects
and some of the [__] I'm watching the
[__] going [__]
I was like speechless I was like how the
[__] did they even do that without
[__] dying yeah I was watching the
podcast about this earlier and the guys
were like like Tom Cruise must just want
to kill himself or the director wants to
kill him like Loki and he's just trying
to the whole time he did some motorcycle
stunts and I'm pretty sure that was him
on that on on the motorcycle yeah I mean
that's kind of one of the selling points
of these movies is I know he can ride I
know he rides well yeah and he does
looks like him because there's a whole
long sequence in the middle and that
because and this has like actually a
decent story too so it's not just like a
bunch of like you know amazing stunt
sequences like just with some crappy
story in between it's actually like
really good and it really keeps going
but it's like um there's a really long
really good sequence that's in set in
Rome and it's just like a car motorcycle
chase like several several cars and like
this little Fiat at uh you know Tom
Cruise on his motorcycle and like this
big [__] armored [__] that's like
running into all the police cars and
going up and down the steps and [__]
like that so it's like it's really
really good and it looks like almost all
of that was done practically yeah which
at least most of what you see on screen
yeah yeah I think you know like I said
they're they're probably removing safety
harnesses and [__] like that yeah
because like I said
people would just people would die I
mean people could die anyway even if
they do have harnesses and [__] on
because it does happen there's a really
good train wreck scene at the end
there's just a lot of good scenes that's
right that train scene at the end
because that's kind of like the big
final sequence like the big set piece
that they're building up to and it's
like man that some that was stressing me
out yeah that [__] was stressing me out
and there was um
real good scene where uh
the IMF stashed him a secret spy car and
he goes to try to find he's using his
little he doesn't know what it looks
like what would he use a cell phone
I was gonna figure out which one it was
yeah something like that because I guess
bodies and all this [__] and he's like
oh nice that's why he's going oh it's
one of these he goes like that it was
actually a little Ford 500 little yellow
one a little Fiat yeah yeah and he's
handcuffed yeah if yeah 500 and um he's
handcuffed to the thief and they're
fighting she doesn't really want to go
and he gets in there and starts to drive
it's electric yeah and [__] [__] tons
of electric powers really fast but it's
so small it just wants to spin in a
circle and [__] light the tires up
and they have a whole chase scene with
that they can barely control the car and
their handcuffed together and she
doesn't want to drive and it's like so
they're going like yeah
and uh
it's funny because Tom's got some kind
of comedic relief in that scene
where he's going takes me a few seconds
he's [__] the car the car is so fast
and the wheels are so small this just
lights the tires up and the car just
spins and does figure eights you know
billowing [__] black smoke from the
tires lighting up
and he's going like they it takes me a
while to get into it it's a new car it's
new I've never driven this one trying to
get the feel for it eventually he
figured he gets the feel for it though
and uh Little Things [__] fast
um
they wreck it of course
um they wreck a lot yeah
[Laughter]
um overall I would say um
very much like a Daniel Craig James Bond
movie but very much of a of an American
tone to it
it seems like it feels like it's
happening in the same universe
um
it's it's just good I put it up there
same kind of thing an exotic locations
um more chases more Tom Cruise acting
ass more [__] more stuff he does
things a little bit different I think
than what James Bond would do
um like there are certain situations
where
his name's Ethan isn't it yeah Ethan
Ethan Hunt yeah he uh probably should
have killed a female agent but he let
her live
and James Bond Daniel Craig James about
probably would have killed her yeah but
she it kind of served this the story
because
she was kind of later on and later on in
the story
she betrays her boss over it and uh
starts helping Ethan because he had
spared her life so I guess maybe that
was the right thing to do but I think in
a James Bond movie he would have killed
her yeah probably yeah
um but the thing about what I was going
to say is that I think these are similar
to the James Bond films like the new
Daniel Craig ones but different in a lot
of because those are generally like
pretty serious and a lot more grounded
in reality there's humor in the James
Bond but not very much whereas these
ones have a lot more humor in them not
not to the fact where it's like zany or
goofball or anything like that but it
does have like a lot more humor in it
especially like with the side characters
and I will say that it's like a little
bit more or maybe a lot more like
outlandish and it's not really supposed
to be realistic I mean the machine that
they have where they can do like these
completely realistic like faces that
they can just put on people and yeah and
people like totally fall forward they
had they had that in uh the television
series well I know and that's why they
do it in this one but it's just like you
know it brings up so many questions it's
like well does it change the cut the
skin color of their hands and legs and
it's like they just say put that mask on
and I'm gonna say too there's one part
in here where is your voice too right
that's what I mean and it's like a tape
over their throat it's like what if what
if the person that you're impersonating
is like a foot taller than you yeah then
what well you can't do it I guess the
the thief impersonated the uh that that
um
and you could tell that she had brown
eyes instead of blue that's what I was
gonna that's what I was just gonna say
it's just that well I think they just
did that for the movie thing where you
would say you would know that that
wasn't really her yeah but um you know
seemed to be like oh yeah that's the
other character but you would think that
especially like her henchmen and stuff
like that being like
um you know I mean I think you would
notice if I had different color eyes one
day probably yeah you'd be like hey you
must be Tom Cruise in a Jenny mask yeah
and then Tom Cruise would have to have
like but they'd have to like tape big
tits on him yeah if he was being me yeah
he can break it he couldn't do it he
couldn't get the walk down he didn't get
to walk down no he couldn't walk like me
like like a clumsy oaf yeah
especially when you wake up in the
morning she thinks every morning she
shuffles out of the bedroom
well you know my joints aren't working
yeah I'm old
and I'm just like I don't want to be out
of bed right now I don't want to be out
of bed right now yes I'm like walking
[__] I'm doing the zombie shuffling
the uh but I uh I thought it was a great
movie I recommend it
it is a lot of fun like I said
um it's I and I liked like I said I
liked all the characters like Tom Cruise
is great in it but
um you know and all the stunts and
everybody talks about that but I
actually really do like all the kind of
all the side characters that they had
like I said the the new uh recruit that
they have like the pickpocket lady
he's like what's her character's name is
Grace right yeah
um and she's played by uh Haley Atwell
who
she is it me or does she look just like
Kate Beckinsale is she like another she
I don't know I don't know these women
you know what I mean it's just like I
think she she just reminds me of Kate
Beckinsale but it's not it's it's Haley
owl so she's in it and she's great like
her and Tom Cruise like have really good
uh chemistry together and we always like
um Rebecca Ferguson who plays Elsa now
she was in the last one right she was in
Fallout yeah so she's she's the same
chick that was in um Dr sleep she played
rose the Hat yeah that's okay that's the
same that's the same actress she's seen
a lot of stuff but I knew that you would
recognize her from that I didn't
recognize her without the dark hair put
dark hair on her and she just looks just
like Laura yeah our friend Laura yeah
well because that's what when we went to
saw Doctor sleep you know when she
played rose the hat and she had that
kind of outfit and our friend Laura kind
of dresses like that too a little bit
because she does like a lot of Cosplay
and everything so it's just kind of like
yeah we were like holy [__] that looks
just like Laura she does look like a lot
like her but um but yeah so she's great
in this as well and you know we always
like Ving Reigns and sign tag like as
the sort of comic relief kind of
characters I love Simon Pegg anyway like
he's like super funny I like everything
that he's in but I really like their
whole
and you know it's
it's a it's a long ass movie I'm gonna
say that it is like almost three hours
and and I will say that you know that
it's part one
so you know that's gonna end kind of on
a cliffhanger which it sort of does but
I think they did a good job balancing
you know yeah this is gonna have a
second part to it so obviously it's
gonna go on longer with having like a
satisfying ending because it does end at
a good point you know where you're not
just cut it doesn't just like end
abruptly like what the [__] and it's
like oh yeah wait till next year then
you'll figure out what happens you know
what I mean so I think they they got a
good because it had like a really big
that whole train sequence at the end
which was [__] amazing because I
think they've the thing about it though
is that the you know the one of the
coolest stunts in the movie which is you
know Tom Cruise like [__] eating off
that mountain off the on the motorcycle
it's like they already showed it in the
trailer like a bunch of times so it's
almost kind of like I hadn't seen the
trailer so all right so I was impressed
but a lot of people complain they're
like well they should in the trailer
like so many times it's like when you
see it in the movie you're just like oh
there it is again you know what I mean
so maybe they should have like kept it
but it really did do that he really did
do that do that jump I mean yeah and my
stomach just dropped like when I'm
[__] happened oh my God I saw what it
really looked like it was just a ramp
the sloping ramp that went up on the
edge of a cliff
and in the movie they covered that rap
with the CGI Mountain yeah it looks like
he's going up the size of a mountain and
just ramps off of it it was actually
just a ramp that they built and it's
long
like like an Evil Knievel style ramp
right and Tom runs up that wrap
on that Super Moto
and uh he's got a parachute on or was it
yeah because it is a parachute in it
it's not it's not one or a speed Wing or
it's a speed Wing or something like that
it's got a you know just a an exotic
parachute or maybe just a regular
parachute I can't remember
just ramps off the edge it just lets
them lets the motorcycle drop yeah and
the camera follows him
if cameras following him
plummeted out of the earth riding it in
then he [__] because he's like I'm
trying to get away from the mountain I'm
sorry because he's talking to like Simon
this is the speed Wing does all kinds of
loops with it tries to slow down tries
to catch the train to land on it yeah
he's trying to land on a movie he's
trying on moving train which is which is
a runaway train yeah because the bad guy
like made it like yeah slow down you
know what I mean yeah he missed the
Rendezvous point because yeah they sped
the tree sped the train up so he missed
it so he had yeah so he had to like jump
and jump down yeah heads up that whole
sequence like before he jumps off the
mountain like where he's talking to
Simon Pegg like over the uh you know
Benji his time he doesn't character name
um where he's talking to him over the
radio and uh he's like well you can see
the train can't you he's like yeah but
it's like with [__] down there like in
the bathroom and he's just like are you
[__] telling me basically that I have
to jump off this [__] Mountain like
onto this train you know but it's like
it was yeah so that was like a really
funny and he's just like [__] me I just
I really don't want to do this you know
what I mean but like he ends up doing it
anyway but yeah that was
when that happened I was just kind of
like and that wasn't even to me that
wasn't even the most horrifying stuff
the most horrifying [__] was like the
train
um like the train crash you know I mean
like the bridge blowing up and all that
stuff and then like the the car is
coming off the [__] and like Ugh
anything to do with like heights and
stuff I just can't yeah it stresses me
out so much I would say that the biggest
difference between this and a James Bond
movie the newer ones is that bond is
working alone basically he might have a
girl with him you know he's basically
working alone and he's kind of in the
shadows
so it's kind of a darker you a lot of
bond is a little bit darker yeah
this is not the tone isn't quite as dark
because they could all communicate with
each other and they're in a big team so
they're not alone
so it's a little bit different the tone
of it yeah I like it I like that I like
how they have the team and everybody
works together yeah they all know each
other like family yeah I like that
aspect of it where and Tom Cruise is
actually I will say that he um he's
really good about not even though he
always came across to me as like kind of
like a cocky [__] but in these
Mission Impossible movies he really does
seem to allow the other actors
to shine you know what I mean like he's
not just hogging all the attention for
himself even though he's obviously doing
all the super dangerous stunts and
everything even though some of the
actors other actors do him too but
um so so I like that he's
letting the other actors have their time
in the sun I also like that the movie
kind of gave a little bit of background
to how they joined the IMF yeah how they
get in and
um basically they're criminals yeah
they're people that had talented
backgrounds they might have been
something like a spy or a thief and they
just were talented and they got caught
and their choices was he could either go
to prison or you could be the IMF yeah
or you could spend the rest of your life
on the run that type of [__] they'll be
so they give them a choice and so that's
how they join but once they join it's
it's for Life basically yeah it's not
like you can't get out like or you can't
retire yeah and it's like also you know
they get caught they're just everything
they're just going to be denied there's
no government backing
yeah because it's not even because they
even have like a scene toward the
beginning where they're kind of talking
about doing like some Exposition about
the key and like what they think it does
and you know what this AI thing is is
all about
and all that so they have that kind of
scene at the beginning and it sort of
implied that a lot of government higher
up people don't really know about the
IMF so so there's like so it's it's on
like a need to know basis yeah
I think the CIA didn't believe it right
so they're even like more secret than
that yeah you know what I mean like they
don't even they didn't believe they
exist right so they're just like super
super like and why they were talking
about how now that's [__] and all of
a sudden boom some smoke breaks out and
then it turned out to be Tom Cruise he
pulled the [__] mask off he gave the
guy back okay come on let's go he
started talking to him while everybody
was knocked out he was in there yeah the
whole time
and you you don't know that that's Tom
Cruise that's Ethan Hunt yeah you don't
know it's him until it happens you go
something's gonna happen here man
[__] dude at least CIA guys saying
that that IMF is [__] not not a real
thing you know but he was in there the
whole time it's cool it's a cool flick
yeah and I and I like the story is like
kind of
I mean a lot of these and the James Bond
ones too they're like slightly
convoluted but it's not really that hard
to
keep track of I did kind of I was kind
of and I don't want to say too much
about this because it's kind of a
spoiler but I don't um I'm not entirely
sure let's put it this way how
trustworthy some of the people higher
ups were because I was thinking that
it's like oh well this guy
um you know that you thought was
trustworthy and it was like that like he
was backstabbing or he was like double
dealing like is he really or was there
something else going on did I miss that
whole [__] do you know who I'm talking
about yeah like I said like don't spoil
it but yeah so I so I wasn't sure and
because I was kind of like well then the
end happened and I was like oh wait is
that Sinister or is that okay one of the
things you said about the tone is
different than Bond the tone of this is
not that different from no time to die
no time to die I also had some comedy in
there yeah if I like no time to die some
people didn't like it I liked it yeah I
liked it too um
and then they had basically the covid AI
[__] directed coveted weapon that
they had remember that yeah yeah they
had that
um well this is kind of like along that
that you know instead of a an AI
directed virus that could kill your
enemies no matter where they were
everybody had it it's just you could
Target it for an individual person
this is AI and I like the fact that
there that that the CIA and the
government people refer to it as the
entity because it's alive because yeah
because it became sentient yeah they
don't call it like Skynet Skynet is what
they're talking about it's basically
this guy yeah I like that as soon as
they as soon as they started and they
they had a Soviet World War III motif of
where this entity comes from and I was
going oh this is a cool idea man this is
Skynet yeah basically basically they're
gonna go get this guy in it they're
gonna try to stop it
a couple people are trying to stop it
the rest of people are just like no we
want that [__] yeah we're gonna take
over the world yeah so if they can get
control if they have that key
and they know what the key is for and a
lot of them don't know what the key is
for they just know that they need that
key
right they don't know where it is
and uh they have that they'll be able to
control the entity's core functions I
mean theoretically theoretically
it's it's core code if you have access
to that it will obey you so
that's what they want although I wonder
now like in the second part if they're
gonna like find out and they're just
like and ai's like [__] you
um
you're not controlling me [__] I don't
know
I kind of feel like that's what will
happen because I thought I mean the
stakes were really high in this one so I
kind of feel like they're gonna have to
like up the stakes in the second part of
it you know what I'm saying because it's
like you know this is like a world
ending kind of [__] because the AI has
become so powerful even in this first
part of the movie where anybody that
could control it you could destroy the
world if you wanted to yeah like
theoretically yeah and the AI is
extremely smart it can calculate
everything that you will do it kind of
can calculate the future or or a couple
possible Futures and
um depending on how things are going to
go to go down so his like main Emissary
or he he's basically the Messiah of this
thing it listens to everything that the
that the AI wants and it says well and
and it's doing
he's doing what it's telling him to do
which you just got to see the movie to
understand I'm talking about but who to
kill and why what will happen if you
kill this person
um and it can impersonate people's
voices like over Communications and
stuff so it does that a couple times
where it's like you think that like
Ethan thinks he's getting a message from
from a friend of his and it's not the
enemy talking so you don't so you can't
trust anything no or any messages that
you get so everybody has to everybody
has to like emergency like go to analog
[__] because you know what I mean
because they can't um because everything
everything that's digital is compromised
like everything that's and it's internet
related and it's aware enough and
intelligent enough to hire real life
people with electronic money and to give
them orders to go kill you right it's
doing that so
so that it's a it's an awesome idea it's
not sending t1000s or anything it's
sending [__] Mercenaries
which which is much more economically
invisible really yeah I mean why why
build like super Killer Robots when you
can just hire dudes when you just hire
dudes to do so then if they get killed
they just hire another one money time it
prints unlimited money that's what I'm
saying so as long as you have money you
can just hire all the dudes you want and
if they get killed you just hire other
ones yeah Tammy says with the writers
and actors on strike it's going to be a
long time for part two I believe that
part two has already been shot because I
think that they shot both of these back
to back and this was shot back in 2020
or 2021
um so I think that you know part eight I
guess it'd be part eight mission
impossible part eight because this one
was seven I think it's already been shot
I don't know if it's in post-production
or whatever but I but I don't think it's
coming out until next June
I will say that all of the we got there
in time to see all the previews which I
always like to see all the previews
and pretty much every movie in the
preview looked great yeah Napoleon
looked really good yeah I want to see
Napoleon with Joaquin Phoenix yeah that
looks really good and then we started
yeah we saw a preview for uh last Voyage
of the Demeter which I'm really really
excited about that actually starts next
week August or next month rather August
10th August 15th something like that and
then um Oppenheimer I want to see that
that's really good that's coming out
soon
um and then what was the other one well
because Napoleon that's um
I mean he makes good movies but some of
those movies are boring
I don't know that one looks good though
and like I said Joaquin Phoenix always
kind of like [__] goes for it so I
think that it could be I think that
would be really good and like they're
gonna do the 101 they're gonna do the
sequel to Joker
I don't know
yeah Oracle said last Voyage looks
incredible it really does and I have to
say I'm really having this isn't a
spoiler because this is in the trailer
I'm really happy that they made the
vampire look like like Nosferatu like he
or like a strigory you know what I mean
like he doesn't look like don't look at
me I am Dracula you know what I mean he
looks like a Monster yeah like a bat
monster and I was like that's awesome I
like that they went old school with it
and and like I said I don't think that
anybody's done that angle of the Dracula
so I don't know what she's talking about
in the Dracula book
Dracula comes to the uh to the new world
to England yeah England
on a boat and everybody on a boat gets
killed just the boat shows up
everybody's dead in it yeah I was like
everybody knows what the end is gonna be
because it's like well if you Fred
Dracula you know what happened to
everybody else that's the story what
happens on that boat yeah it looks good
they might change it up I don't know
although the fact that they called the
movie The Last Voyage of the debater
yeah it's just kind of because I was
like I read Dracula I know what happens
to all the people on that [__] ship
you know what I mean but it still looks
really really good and I'm like really
excited to see it and like I said
Napoleon I want to see that Oppenheimer
I want to see that actually that Bob
Marley movie looked pretty good too yeah
it looked pretty good gotta say yeah um
and I think there was a couple other
ones that there's another movie I just
saw I just saw a trailer for it looked
pretty good
damn I saw the trailer on YouTube
what is that about something I
recognized and I was like well okay but
I forgot what it was oh
oh no the Meg meg2 oh that's right meg2
looked good I think that's coming out
soon too because I saw a poster for it I
enjoyed it I enjoyed this I liked that
too it was like it was just like a big
dumb fun Church movie we saw it in the
theater and I was like I was smiling the
whole thing I was like yeah okay this
shit's corny as [__] but I love it this
is a corny [__] but this yeah Jason
Statham's there Jason Statham and he was
just State them in the [__] out of that
thing
Jason Statham versus a giant shark yeah
a big shark and there was just can't go
wrong with that I mean really yeah
it was just a fun movie
yeah like the previews for Meg too
because I'm terrified of sharks you know
so I but I like shark movies but they
scare the [__] [__] out of me and
especially if the [__] shark is gonna
be as big as the Meg and obviously the
Meg 2 they're like let's make the shark
like three times bigger so it's like
some of the shots in there it was like
oh my God that's like my [__] worst
nightmare
I think there's gonna be a few good
movies this summer
yeah it does look like a lot of good
ones are coming out Indiana Jones went
down to flames
yeah like I I knew that was gonna be
like I said I heard some pictures like
some people thought it was okay and like
it was better than Crystal Skull but
most people were like yeah
I don't you know
tell me something about franchise they
were talking about it at work and like
one of the ladies there saw it and she
really liked it but she was like a big
Indiana Jones fan so but I was just kind
of like me
I love Indiana Jones too I'm just saying
it's like I didn't really like Crystal
Skull so I didn't realize and he's old
now he's too old yeah I mean and I'm not
[__] on people that are always like
Tom Cruise is old too like you know what
I mean like [__] big difference
though but there's you know I think I
think uh
Tom Cruise isn't 80 though that's true
yeah I think he's only in his 60s yeah I
think Tom Cruise was like seven years
older than me yeah he actually looks
pretty good in the movie yeah you could
he's uh I gotta say you know you got you
know how I am I'm I'm kind of critical
when it comes to uh a man's physique
he was in looks to be in pretty good
shape but I could tell that he has lost
some muscle mass
he used to have like a bigger upper body
a little bit a little bit Slimmer waist
he's
looking a little bit more like a mortal
man which I don't think that's good for
for Tom Tom's never supposed to look
like a mortal man he needs to go back on
cycle
he's got to be on HRT he's got to be I
mean some of the [__] that he does in
this movie yeah I don't even know
[__] man I think like a lot of younger
people in decent shape would have a hard
time with a lot of the stuff so Props to
that like I said yeah he's in good shape
he's in yeah he's in really good shape
and he does like a lot of the [__] he's
climbing around and like I said there's
a whole sequence at the end too like
where him and um Gabriel aside Morales
character are like running on the top of
a train and like to have it's like a big
knife fight and they did that [__] for
Rio yeah they built that train yeah and
they had like and because I was thinking
and because I was watching this other
podcast about it and they were talking
about this featurette like a making of
thing and I was thinking the same exact
thing that there's when they're running
across the train and you know how like
the trellises or whatever not trellises
but the you know the the things that
like overhang the whatever and it's like
and they're having to like duck
underneath like while the train is going
I was like oh well that's gotta be CGA
and it's not those were really there so
they had to like practice
a lot like to to go like underneath
those [__] things so they didn't get
their head knocked off you know what I
mean I think like I said I think some of
the other actors did use a stunt double
and I'm not blaming them for that
because some of the stunts in this were
like [__] insane but Tom crew as far
as I know uh did all the [__] himself
like pretty much look who Victor said
what do you say
I read uh I read Tom Cruise credits his
youthful appearance of being a Powerpuff
maybe that's what it is maybe Tom Cruise
made you gay Victor yeah yeah
I said uh they're not going as fast as
they made it look like on the film well
yeah that's what they always do and I
think that happens like any time well I
mean they did that in any kind of big
stunt Extravaganza we did Mad Max that's
I was gonna say they did that in Fury
Road as well it's like the stunts and
that still look [__] incredible and
remember when we saw that movie like six
times in the theater yeah we even Mad
Max one that Max one yeah they just they
speed everything up yeah it's just like
and they can do it better nowadays
because back in the old days like in the
70s and 80s like you could tell you
could tell that they had sped the film
up it's like hey let's just drive 20
miles an hour yeah so it's safer and
then we'll speed it up to look like
we're going like 100 but now they can do
it like a lot better so it does so like
in Fury Road they did do all that [__]
they were like jumping from car to car
and like going underneath and [__] like
that they were going slower than it
looked like I think they were going back
I mean still that's pretty fast though I
mean if you're jumping that's what I
mean it's like you're still doing that
I'm not jumping from car to car going
for 40 miles an hour [__] that [__]
you'll bust your [__] head open but
yeah so and they were wearing harnesses
too that they just like you know erased
in and that's kind of the same thing
that was happening here but because
which one was it was it Fallout or Ghost
Protocol or it was one of the other
Mission Impossible movies where Tom
Cruise climbed up that big at like the
tallest building in the world or
whatever which is it's in Dubai right
yeah I don't know like he climbed up the
glass like kind of up and down and he
did actually do that but he was wearing
a harness but like it wasn't a free I
swear to God I I've seen all these
movies and I don't remember I just
remember liking them yeah I remember
certain parts certain scenes but I got
to go back and I gotta back and see
remember I don't I've only seen him once
seven eight times
so I gotta go back and watch them
multiple times
I remember I remember really like I
liked Fallout I remember really liking
Fallout a lot what was the other one
ghost protocol Ghost Protocol was I
think the one before that that was the
sit no yeah the fifth one I think I
don't know this one is the seventh one
and Fallout was the last one that came
out in 2018 and then the one before that
was Ghost Protocol I think yeah and then
before the Rogue Nation Rogue Nation
that's right or maybe Rogue nation was
after it goes vertical now I can't
really think Rogue Nation Ghost Protocol
um fallout Fallout and then are the best
ones from from whatever man I think
that's what most people say like I've
seen I saw the first mission impossible
movie
um which I didn't love it because it was
it seemed like it was a lot cheesier
yeah it was corny like it like more in
line with I guess more like what the TV
show was like so they were trying to
make it more tonally like that and then
the second one which is the John Woo one
which is pretty universally like the
least favorite among fans of the
franchise
just because it was kind of goofy
um I think they didn't really get good
until like the fourth or fifth one I
feel like in defense of the John Woo
movie
at the time that they made that movie
that was a really hot director
and what he was doing was very kind of
like new and hip and that was kind of
like everybody liked it at the time just
that didn't age well right some things
don't you never know it's style didn't
age well
um Camp guy said uh that was mission
possible I saw with my son was not
really impressed with that one in Dubai
yeah I can't even remember which one
that was but I remember that being a
pretty amazing stunt because like I said
you're not getting my ass to climb up a
building that's for sure even if I do
have a harness on it man like I said I
don't I think he's nuts because of that
Scientology thing yeah and all of that
and I and I probably wouldn't like him
as a person because he seems like a
douche but props like he he'll do all
his own stuff he can't really do all
that [__] like he does really do all
that [__] and he really does seem to
like care about making a really good
movie that everybody wants to come see I
think this is
um one of the most expensive movies ever
made okay
290 million dollars dude something like
that I should do well I think it'll do
well yeah it um I think the for this
opening weekend it didn't make quite as
much as they were expecting
um but I imagine that it will probably
make its money back and then some
because it seems like on Rotten Tomatoes
it's 96 positive reviews like all the
credit 6 or 11 this [__] Tom can act he
can shoot
he's good he can ride motorcycles he can
fly aircraft
um what else can he do
he can stop space time continuum and go
back and fix a mistake that he did yeah
just like that right yeah yeah he can
turn the world backwards yeah and make
and make Margo Kidder come back yeah
[__] with the whole track
that's what he can do
oh oh and let me uh uh you say this
which is not really related to the movie
but sort of
is that when we got to because like I
said the theater where we go it's at the
Lake Square Mall which is it's not a
dead Mall because it's busy but it is
kind of uh not not in the best condition
let's put it that way yeah so um so yeah
so that's where the theater is and it
happens to be right next to the uh
Ichiban Buffet where we usually go for
lunch yeah it's like right and there's
the Books a Million there that we always
go in probably make the fat people and
the mall is where all the fat people go
I want to feed the other yeah pretty
much yes and then there's a press and
there's a Dunkin Donuts right next to
the Ichiban too so you can like hit both
of the things you can go to there and
then everybody everybody looked retired
and everybody looked like they weren't
from Florida
that area
is that area right around that mall is
there's a lot of there's a lot of kind
of like fancy gated communities but then
there's a whole bunch of like sort of
fancy like retiree mobile home parks
yeah too so that's like where a lot of
them go so it's like a lot of older
Snowbird type people like like old fat
white people
um and then like hanging out going to
ichibano it's like well we can't
complain I mean we go to Ichiban on The
Saturdays too yeah because man it's
[__] it's like 14 a person and you
can eat as much as you want and then a
world sure if you want and the food's
actually good yeah pretty good yeah the
food's actually good yeah but so so we
went to Ichiban and then we still had
a while like before the movie started
and so we went over to books a million
and kind of hung out and like got some
coffee and whatever and it so happened
that they were having a cat adoption
event yeah in the books a million and
she said that they have one like every
other Friday because there's a pet
there's a Petco or PetSmart or one of
those like in the mall too and I don't
know if it was in conjunction with them
so the cafe like in the books a million
was just full full of kitties yeah and
we're gonna get Pookie a friend
eventually we were thinking about it
like we were talking to the lady they
were actually from a place what'd they
say hofmeyer Animal Center and she told
us where it was and they mostly had
kittens but they had like some grown-up
cats too and I was like oh my God
because we were just sitting over there
at the bar like drinking the coffee and
like looking at the kitties and I'm like
oh my God I want to go over there like
look it's like I better not because if I
pick one up then I'll just be like I'm
gonna take all these kitties home with
me Victor mentioned that [__] Tom
Cruise can jump also he can't right [__]
it right he did not only jump on that
sofa he surfed on that
surf on that [__] yeah hahaha
[__] time
but but yeah Zoom so we saw the kitties
and it was very exciting and there was
like a ton of people in there and I
think one of the kittens got adopted
because when we got there uh it was a
girl and I guess her boyfriend or her
husband or something and this little
black kitten sat on his shoulder and
like fell asleep on his shoulder and he
was just walking around with his little
kitty like on her shoulder it was like
hilarious so I think they did adopt that
that one so they were trying to get like
kitties adopted out so we were talking
to this lady
and we were kind of like well we can't
do anything now because you know we
don't have the money but um because they
and because they have these two kittens
that were brother and sister and they
were trying to like adopt them together
because they were like really closely
bonded and they didn't want to be apart
which you know you shouldn't do that if
they're that close and I was kind of
like I kind of want both of those
kitties but um that was 225 which isn't
terrible because they you know they spay
them and give them their shots and
everything like that but we had been
thinking about
um maybe getting Pookie a little buddy
at some point not a kitten kitten maybe
like maybe somebody like closer I don't
know closer her own age because she's
six but yeah more like a year probably
maybe like a year or two because I mean
even though Pokey is six because Tom is
telling the ladies like she's pretty
rambuncious yeah and it's like I mean
she is she's like a kitten even though
she's like a grown-up cat so I don't so
I don't know how I'm not really sure how
she would react like if we got another
cat like maybe she'd love it and maybe
she would beat up on it I'm not really
sure I just I kind of feel like they
really have these things where you take
your cat over there and you and you can
introduce and see which ones yeah that
seems like a good idea yeah and then
whatever cat your cat likes that's the
one you take yeah that's probably the
best thing to do because I'm not really
sure it's because me and Tom were like
well should we get somebody or should we
get a cat like with the same personality
as pookie would they just like tear the
house up like would they all be in
cahoots and be like we're gonna destroy
everything you know what I mean would
they would they just like egg each other
on to like worse and worse behavior I'm
not really sure I don't know or maybe
because I kind of feel like if we got
one that was kind of chill like Pookie
would just like get bored or like beat
the [__] out of her so I'm not really
sure like she does the beige yeah
[Laughter]
yeah Beijing is well she's older I mean
she's what 14 yeah something like that
baby [__] so she doesn't like that baby
[__] and she's just like look I just
want to sleep and look fluffy and pretty
and everything and they get along but
you know they don't play together they
don't play you know what I mean like
Pookie will be down there and she kind
of looking at her and like Beijing will
try to come up the stairs like sneak
around and Pookie would be like what are
you doing up here these kisses at her
and then okay get the [__] away from me
baby we're done with the review yeah
okay let's go
okay yeah Tom's getting cranky yeah well
we gotta do the movie review
what are you talking about we did the
movie review oh you said you got to do
the movie I'm like we just did it it's
just a movie review yeah okay all right
so uh so yeah so it's a good movie go
see it it's a fun popcorn movie and I
would actually recommend seeing it in
the theater because it's probably like
way better like on the big screen yeah I
recommend it yeah even though we didn't
see it in IMAX or anything like that but
it was still like pretty [__]
impressive gotta say so uh so yeah so
tomorrow is Monday and that means it's a
haunting Mondays so the episode we're
gonna do which we've already watched
actually and I already took notes on is
called evil Never Dies it's uh season
seven
episode four I believe it's actually
like a pretty decent episode I'd kind of
forgotten about it so that's the one
that we're going to be doing tomorrow
and also if you didn't see my message
over on patreon or uh in the YouTube
Community tab I also said that even
though
uh you know because I usually run the
polls like for the topics and everything
even though what one in the polls was
killer moms uh you know Susan Smith and
uh Andrea Yates that's what we were
gonna do but because of the whole Long
Island serial killer thing like all that
news and everything so I think on this
Wednesday show we're gonna do like a
Long Island serial killer update and
then we're gonna move the killer mom
show like to the following week so this
Wednesday we're gonna do a Long Island
serial killer like revisit because
there's going to be all kind of
information
about that dude and we're gonna like
talk about that and I didn't realize how
long ago we had done that Long Island
serial killer show we did that back in
2018. okay so that was like yeah it was
a long time ago so there has been like
obviously some development since then so
we're going to be talking about that and
then we'll move the other show
to the following week so hopefully
that's okay with everybody so uh yeah
have a good rest of your evening you
guys and we will see you guys again for
the haunting show tomorrow night good
night